hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we have some very
exciting news to share because after
what have
might felt like just a bit of a mild
eternity we finally have confirmation
that there will be an anime adaptation
of part six of jojo's bizarre adventure
stone ocean this announcement happened
during a three-hour live streamed event
which featured all six
yes six jojo protagonist voice actors
all of which read iconic scenes from
their respective series
in fact here's an image of the event
featuring script segments and these like
beautifully ornately crafted books it's
just so
damn jojo isn't it and very exciting
because right in the foreground we can
see the long awaited stone ocean where
the trademark symbol is a butterfly get
used to the butterfly we'll be seeing it
a lot just like how you often see me
subtly hint towards you subscribing to
the new world review which may or may
not result in regular injections of jojo
content administered straight into your
youtube feed so
best not to take the risk just do it but
the online reaction to this announcement
was pretty damn amazing actually i felt
for quite some time that the jojo niche
of anime and manga has felt a bit
i don't know like a bit dormant because
yeah we've got part 8 being serialized
monthly but the sheer love or perhaps
even lust for jojo felt like it was
dissipating quite a bit as it turns out
that was very
very wrong because each and every one of
us immediately rose up
in response to this announcement and one
response i'd like to highlight comes
from the twitter account simply entitled
is stone ocean confirmed which i've been
following ever since finishing golden
wind and in one glorious tweet we
finally have what we've been waiting for
day
616 stone ocean is confirmed thank you
everyone for coming on this journey with
me
it's been a blast and this post garnered
over 100
000 likes and this of course was
immediately followed by an account named
steel ball run confirmed popping up
which uh oh i don't know i think you
might have a long
time to wait my friend although i do
love your location san diego to new york
very very clever
sometimes twitter can be fun but that's
something i wanted to touch on actually
the idea that people are legitimately
excited for part 6 because that's not
quite the reception i would have
expected it to get just from my
anecdotal experience of jojo fans what i
expected was something more along the
lines of great let's animate stone
ocean so that we can get to steel ball
run and i've seen surprisingly little of
that in fact i myself am shocked at just
how hyped i am to see a part 6 anime but
before we go any further in case you're
not familiar with stone ocean here is
the general
non-spoilery premise the series follows
jolene kujo the troublesome daughter of
the even more troublesome jyotaro cujo
and after an instant where jolene is
wrongly convicted of a crime she is sent
to prison and thus the setting becomes a
jailbreak story although as is jojo that
general premise gets twisted
quite a bit and if you don't already
know the story let me tell you you have
no chance of predicting what kind of
wild ride you're about to go on
in terms of setting this time around we
find ourselves back in the united states
of florida to be precise
so definitely leave all of your dreams
of beautiful italy with part five
because the us
does things just a little bit
differently now while we have very few
details regarding the actual production
in fact at this stage we don't even have
a release date
although with that in mind if we do go
by the golden win standards and the
premiere of the first episode was shown
something crazy like only a month after
the announcement of the series
and the entire series began airing about
three months after the announcement
so we could be hit in the face with some
jojo glory far
far quicker than anticipated although
with that said it could also take far
far longer so don't get your hopes up
too far and maybe you'll be in for some
sort of pleasant surprise but one thing
we do know is the all-important voice
actor of jolene her name is iferuz
and i do apologize because i don't know
how to properly pronounce her last name
she's half japanese half egyptian and
look my mastery of arabic is
it's non-existent so this is the one
time that i will consensually allow you
to correct me in the comments but i
is a very exciting person because jolene
isn't just another role to her jolene is
very much her dream character and i has
made the following comments i cannot
live without jojo's bizarre adventure
and it's also what inspired me to take
up voice acting as a profession so when
i heard that i was going to be able to
participate in the series i was lost for
words
and surprised because even a stand would
have had me over the moon i cried so
much as it was literally the moment my
dream came true which i've chased for
over 12 years i love and admire jolene
as a character and her beautiful strong
nature gave me strength especially
during my student years so i am grateful
for the opportunity to voice jolene so
it's hard to call her anything less than
perfect for the role and you can hear
her voicing jolene in the teaser trailer
for part six it's very very brief but i
think it gives quite a good impression
and
i am really excited to hear her going
forward oh and one other thing is that
during the announcement event i was
welcomed on stage by daisuke ono who is
the prolific voice of jolene's father
jotaro which is another thing that might
be fun to know if you're not too
familiar with stone ocean jotaro is very
much back after his extended absence
during golden wind so if you're a jotaro
fan then huzzah
and if you're not then well my apologies
and i guess you'll just have to deal
with it also this announcement event
came equipped with a message from
hirohika araki himself which
he really didn't say too much it was
just confirmation that yes the anime is
in production a bit about what stone
ocean is and of course to look forward
to it it was a very quintessential
japanese public statement which is
designed to make it sound like someone
is you know actually saying something
but in reality it's not really a whole
lot of anything it is always nice to see
arkey though because
he's immortal i mean this guy is 60
years old and still has that baby face
it is ridiculous
the reason why i do bring this up though
is because there is a perhaps
questionable translation in this message
where araki says
look forward to the theatrical release
which is a very exciting word in english
because that would imply that perhaps
the first couple of part six episodes
are going to have some sort of limited
cinematic release which i would
absolutely be down for but given how
sloppy the translations were for the
rest of the event with the auto english
generated subtitles
look i wouldn't read too much into it
because they clearly didn't put all that
much effort into it it really could just
be a bit of a mistake and he's saying
you know look forward to the release
or the television premiere or whatever
any number of other things
here's the thing about part six though
it's very hard to talk about or at least
i've found it quite difficult to discuss
without diving into a gigantic
bit of controversy if we disregard
phantom blood then i would say that
stone ocean is the most consistently
lowest ranked part of jojo in terms of
fan opinion
and there's a wide array of reasons for
that because let's just say that
stone ocean it makes some decisions and
potentially unpopular decisions but it
is very
bold in doing so i also don't think it's
really a series that can truly be
appreciated upon first read through
which would have also contributed
heavily to its negative perception
and by the way i am personally very much
a part of that in my review of stone
ocean from way way way back
i would definitely say that i was i was
definitely far from impressed
i had quite a lot of criticisms many of
which i do still retain to this very day
but i have gone back on it since and let
me tell you that stone ocean is a
completely different experience the
second time around
if you were not satisfied by it the
first time once you know what you're in
for and just
enjoying jojo for the sake of whatever
jojo is part six is
it's actually pretty damn incredible
especially in regards to the stands i
think that stone ocean has most of my
favorite stands in the entire
series there's a lot of pikachu
happening here when it comes to stance
his mind is just something else entirely
during the spot but the thing i'm most
excited for
is a potential redemption of stone ocean
within the jojo fanbase sort of like
what i'm told what happened with part
five apparently back in the day golden
wind was viewed pretty damn negatively
which was perhaps due to some not so
great english translations ah and
speaking of yeah
i understand i'm going on a bit of a
tangent here but how bizarre is it that
we still don't have an official english
translation for the entirety of part
four i believe we'll have the full thing
by next month but that's insane we don't
have a full official release for part
four let alone
five six seven or eight so the
perception of everything from stone
ocean onwards is
really down to fan translations but what
i was trying to say is that the golden
wind anime gave part five something of a
renaissance a renewed vigor and
appreciation so i very much hope that
something like that happens with part
six where we have a competent and
faithful production team which are able
to elevate the source material within
the anime medium but you know what it's
not just jojo fans that are excited
because there's even a few comments on
this channel from non-jojo fans as well
i've never watched jojo's bizarre
adventures but a lot of people have been
hyping this up so maybe i should give
the series a try
and yes absolutely you should but if you
are watching this video out of some sort
of state of you know jojo curiosity then
i would say that this
is a very very good moment in time to
start that journey but i really would
emphasize that you do not want to start
with stone ocean
do not wait for the series to release
and then jump into it that way
no go back on part one and do it
properly yes it's a bit of a slog as
part one is
ah despise part one but stone ocean is
probably the only part of jojo's bizarre
adventure that really does not work at
all in isolation
beautiful now announced part 7 and part
8.
look i hear you but stone ocean is a
pretty essential step in getting there
although part 8 in particular is still
oh that's such a far away dream
please bring back jojo monday all right
uh so back in the day every monday on
this channel used to be dedicated to a
jojo video and i don't think i've ever
stated this publicly but i had to stop
doing them because like i said earlier i
began to encounter quite a dissipation
and interest in jojo which may not have
anything to do with the series itself it
might be entirely how i was presenting
it
either way i needed to take a step back
but i would be very keen to hop back
into some regular jojo content i really
do miss covering the series because it
is one of the most unique properties in
all of media so if you want to see that
i guess let me know somehow by
commenting or liking subscribing
the youtube things you all know what
they are i wonder what songs they'll
choose for the endings
yes this is a big big stone ocean
question so for some context stone ocean
takes place in the year 2011 however it
was actually serialized in real life
between 2000 and 2003. so it's quite
difficult to predict which era the
musical choices for the endings may come
from
it could be the early 2000s and stuff
that arki was listening to whilst
writing the series but for the sake of
tying into the timeline of the series
itself i'm hoping for more of that 2011
vibe but definitely let me know what
sort of ending songs you would like to
see in the comments thing
yes sir best girl jolene and snail's
hype
snails yeah right ah there's going to
come a point where i
i guess i really hope that you guys like
snails and frogs weird weather in
general really be open
to weather in part six is it weird just
how
excited i get for a trailer that
basically just said the thing i already
knew
and then played a jojo theme they don't
even need to try and get me high
it's true the teaser trailer really
doesn't give you much if anything to
work with but there is one thing that i
do want to point out very very subtle
thing but as we travel through all of
the past
jojo's we're doing so through what looks
like strands of string
which is super incredibly appropriate
and a nice hint to jolene standstone
free
yes yes yes yes yes perfectly said sir
but if you'd like to check out some more
jojo content i have an entire playlist
dedicated to the series including my
reviews of each part of the series
plenty of fun to be had so i look
forward to seeing you there